casey myers like chef just mentioned his
15th start today
and uh he was originally scheduled for
the second game of this series uh with
the rain out yesterday or excuse me the
third game of this series with the rain
out yesterday he will be moved to game
one and we're quite honestly glad he is
this is an important game got a tough
pitcher against us 17 homers and 41 runs
driven in for jose altuve
and he drives an o2 pitch to left for a
base hit so it makes him such a great
hitter he gets behind the count but then
he gets a hanging slider stays up in the
zone doesn't break much at all and he
hammers it to left field now two they on
the go again and this ball is grounded
to the right side that'll be a base hit
altuve will go first to third michael
brantley
what else
another base hit the base hit ho-hum
31-62 since coming off the il it's nice
to be mike right now i want to be like
mike this is the time to be like mike
here's the 1-2 to correa
off the mound mize has got it
he throws him out
he strands two singles you may not think
it's a big deal but it is
bottom of the first inning robert valdez
getting the ball for game one
robbers four and all with a one six
seven twenty nine based on excuse me 29
strikeouts nine base on balls and the
key number there is the base on balls
proper stroke strikes he pitches deep
into the game
nothing to be said that he wouldn't do
that the same thing today
the 02
swing and a miss good morning good
afternoon and good night robbie grossman
got a curveball three pitch strikeout
picks up a foul tip strike out there
on robbie grossman there's robel garcia
tigers shifting him to the right side
again
on the ground and nice play made by zach
short and he throws him out
that was a big league play right there
zach short
all the way flat out to his left
dives the ball finds his glove and then
he pops up makes a throw over to scope
makes it look almost routine that ball
came out hot too it was at 104 miles
bottom of the second inning miguel
cabrera the designated hitter will lead
things off for detroit he's hitting 222
287 on base percentage five homers 28
rbis ground ball base hit
in between correa and garcia miguel hit
it hard on cue miguel cabrera delivers a
base hit to left that's number 2912.
a one-out single for eric haas has given
detroit runners at the corners the 2-1
fly ball right field should get the job
done tucker's back he's got it cameron
tags
the tigers have the one-nothing lead on
the sacrifice fly from isak paredes
so now first and second for carlos
correa with two outs he batted last time
with first and third with two outs and
grounded out on a nice play
there's a line drive base hit the left
euleguer yellow will score over to third
goes alvarez carlos correa does it again
rbi base hit we're tied at one that's
what you call
understanding what's going on and you're
at bat here's jason castro
one out away from a quick inning to
center field hit pretty well cameron
going back twisted twice and then makes
the grab falling down
he got turned around not once but twice
but he kept the focus and hold it in for
the third out of the inning boy that's a
highlight
film right there hold it how do you make
that catch and then dove dan on the
warning track wow and caught the ball
that's a big time play fantastic
it always seems like when a guy makes a
nice play defensively he's up at the
plate next half inning
yep that one that ball hit into center
diving catch by chaz mccormick
chaz mccormick robs the other
centerfielder daz cameron who just
robbed jason castro last inning pitching
in defense that's how you win
doesn't read it real well right off the
crack of the bat but he makes up ground
tigers now with a runner in scoring
position with one out zach short hit a
double over center fielder chaz
mccormick's head his first time up in
the third
see if he can get himself his first
major league rbi here
drives one to deep right field back goes
tucker back goes tucker and it's gone a
home run for zach short
he does more than driving the run
he homers his first at the major league
level and the tigers lead at 3-1
well there should be some excitement in
that dugout zach short
has got a little bit more power than
people want to
recognize and give him credit for that
was opposite field we've seen that
before adam we saw
a couple balls hit hard like that in
spring training out of zach
and it couldn't have come at a better
time for the tigers
27th man my foot
middle of the plate away
but look at the focus and concentration
seema will break that down post game i'm
sure but that ball was greeted perfectly
and he drives it over the right field
wall
367 feet for zach short his first major
league homer
and the first two rbis at the major
league level as well
a two-run cushion now for casey mize
change up
wow
that's ball four
kyle tucker that's ball four
isn't it did we lose count
yeah
that's ball four right yeah
okay he's staying in there talk he
wanted another piece of it go ahead and
get the first i guess we had the count
wrong it's three and two i guess we did
now it's ball four
tucked nose
tuck knows
17 chases of the day so far
the only way that happens is it gets
ahead and count another splitter coming
here the 2-2
he got him staring
that's a nice way to end the day for
casey mais strikeout number five
leave another man aboard for houston
this was nasty just as chaz mccormick
and it stays 3-1
jose cisnero is on
in the seventh
two for three in save situations and he
will face
castro and then
jose altuve and michael brantley
another 3-2
popped it up right side of the infield
zach short called for it and he's got it
here's the 3-2
he got him staring
with conviction two away two away in the
seventh for michael brantley
he sits him down and closes it out the
tigers win it three to one
casey mize zach short and jose cisnero
in the seventh